just like that we've seen stuff like
that because the games uh I've always
said you know it doesn't matter if it's
not in Game Pass Microsoft just to be
aggressive and make sure these games at
least come to the platform and I like
that was in the platform you know when
it comes to vow I liked what I saw vow
there's like a lot of weird energy
around a v like I still don't understand
what like look I was the first person
and I still hold by you know what they
showed of us at that first starting
trailer this it was very dark very it's
not representative of what we're seeing
but that doesn't mean the game's going
to be bad like once again I can love
something and still criticize it may I
have to repeat that that I can love
something and criticize all things I
think we got to beef with each other and
call each other dayses but we disagree I
just yeah people are like and that's
what we do now